in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Gregg
and Kim are with us how are you great
doing fine how are you better than I
deserve for you guys from Desoto Texas
wonderful now where is that in Texas
right next to Dallas oh okay perfect
that I know all right cool
here to do it that free scream how much
have you paid off 160 thousand change
yeah instant change I'm nervous that's
okay I'm sorry we've never lost a
patient you'll be all right thank you
okay
160 thousand five hundred and
sixty-seven dollars and 80 cents I love
it and how long did that take about
eight and a half years Wow to go way to
go cool and your range of income during
those years we started out when we
started doing this we were probably
making about 120 and now we're probably
around 180 maybe a little more wow
you're doing very well what do you guys
do for a living I am a registered nurse
there we go
I'm a Dallas firefighter oh very cool
very cool
well first responders had a tough week
down there this week they didn't we've
been praying for you guys thank you so
you wow that's a tough time and the
funeral is running right the funerals
are running right now on the memorial
service on the on the Fox News live as
we speak so yeah tough times well thanks
for stopping by you guys what kind of
debt was the hundred and sixty one
thousand okay I have that written down
to some of his medical debt we had a car
in there there was some hospital bills
we have 401 Loans and the rest of it was
consumer debt alright so what happened
eight and a half years ago that made you
guys decide to attack this well um I was
at a Bible study group and one of the
ladies in the group mentioned that she
was debt free outside of her mortgage
Wow and that sounded really weird to me
and and she had been doing the Total
Money Makeover and she gave me the book
why don't and I read it and I brought it
home to him and I teasingly refer him
of friends and family that he's the
black Dave Ramsey there you go all right
he might be better-looking than me we
got the same haircut though and he took
the bull by the horn and off we went
there we go perfect so you didn't have
to talk him into it it just he needed an
excuse was all right okay fine fine and
now here you are you're weird yeah
you've joined the weird Club that's a
good thing because normals broke we
don't be normal well I needed the
knowledge you know I I promised her
mother and her father and and God I
would take care of her when I married
her
and I was going the wrong way when she
brought me that cotton pickin book I
went Jesus I'm going the wrong way and
it angered me it I mean it just really
made me angry so I turned around and I
ran just as hard in the other direction
which is the direction that you teach
you know that's why that's what in the
spiritual world that's what we call
repentance right yes did a 180 baby
there we go
back the other way wide open and well
congratulations you guys what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is for I think delayed
gratification hmm
and now it's a practice that I kind of
enjoy but delay gratification we missed
some vacations with family and the women
would pull me over to the side and say
hey talk him into it now I'm like no I'm
on board with this plan so we're gonna
stick with it well I think they think
that I joined a cult and they might have
felt like I was holding her hostage or
our family never does anything like that
yeah
that's five years now you brought your
kids with you yes sir and how old are
they one is 12 and the other one is 15
their names
Elijah and Mantha okay they're gonna
join us on this debt free scream yes sir
reluctantly they will reluctantly
alright reluctantly drag them over there
that's fun perfect perfect perfect what
was the hardest part
this for you guys getting out of that
I'm gonna say the delay gratification
that was putting things off it's the key
but it was the hardest part yes that you
normally would go and swipe a card for
so just saving in paying cash for me it
was the 4:01 stuff you know that for old
one stuff pays you know I always looked
at for old ones as me borrowing money
from me so I didn't think it was
borrowing money yeah and I wanted to
come probably a year ago and you know
she enlightened me she's like no that's
borrowed money
you are still in debt yeah so we paid
off everything sixty thousand of that
was 401 long Wow okay yeah I needed to
be cleaned up yeah what a great job I'm
very proud of you guys now we got a copy
of Chris Hogan's book retire inspired
because that takes you to the next level
now it's time to build wealth you got
rid all these payments now it's time to
become wealthy yes sir and I live like
no one else so later you can live and
give like no one else so we'll have a
signed copy of Christmas book for you
returns fire alright it's Greg and Kim
Elijah and Matthew from the Dow's Texas
area one hundred and sixty one thousand
dollars paid off in eight and a half
years making 122 now 180 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream alright
three two one
that's how it's done right there folks
that's exactly how it's done Wow
very well done you guys love it love it
love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind